Being a hero.
It's not about glory.
It's about sacrifice.
We've trained the best and brightest
young heroes since 1965.
Welcome to Godolkin University.
Godolkin is a safe space for you to thrive.
What up?
What?
But you have a target on your back
Marie Moreaux
You could be the first top
ranked freshman in history,
I think you meant to say
First Black woman in the seven.
a few of us are going off campus.
Let's have a good time.
I'm still drunk from last night.
Perfect. Just take a sip.
Say turbo rush cures hangovers.
Pour this on my giving your cancer.
There are dangerous, evil people
at that school.
Everything is
Freshman class is savage just here
I exploded his tag team explosion. Wow.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my brand new Boys
Gen V trailer.
This is meant to be a spin off of the boys
that'll take place between season
three and season four. I believe.
As you can see, a bunch of characters
from the boys like Homelander, Ashley.
A-Train.
PJ Burns, director, character,
a bunch of others, even
Victoria Neuman, are back for the series.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do episode videos
for when it premieres,
which they say is going to be in
September.
is meant to bridge the gap between season
three and season four.
end, even though the showrunner
of the boys
said he's
not going to premiere season four
until the whole
big strike is done, really.
Though they finished shooting it a while
ago, they just been doing post-production,
so it's going to take a while
to finish season four.
Anyway, so it's not like
they've completely finished season four
and it's just sitting on a shelf
waiting to come out.
They're still actually working
on the episodes.
It's not ready to be released
no matter what that'll probably wind up
releasing sometime spring 2024,
maybe early summer at the latest.
but basically the idea with the spinoff
here is they
have this university
called Goodluck in university God U,
which is meant to be a VOC
controlled school
that they used to pick through
all the compound bee babies
to find one that they can actually use to
make more money off of they're building.
The show is a little bit like X-Men,
like Xavier's School for gifted youngsters
in the Boys, Universal, X-Men in the Boys
universe, mixed with The Hunger Games
as they're all fighting for a chance
to join
the Seven in the whole Hunger
Games thing is the idea
that they're basically
killing each other off.
last person standing
gets a chance to join the seven.
the hoity in the boys universe is that
with very few exceptions across history,
parents will submit their children
for compound B testing
because at least
at the present day compound
the only really worked on children
when adults would take it,
it would just wind up making them explode.
recently.
They changed that
with the temporary compound.
B Like now
you see adults being able to take it
and it's a slightly different form
of the compound.
B but all the older children
and all the adults
who would have taken it
with the exception of Ryan and Homelander,
were basically dosed with compound B when
they were children as part of experiments
just to become part of
what's testing, to see if they could make
a better version of the formula
or if they could make a superhero
that they can make a ton of money off of
that was the real reason.
Like, hey, you submit your child,
you have a chance
to earn a lot of money off of them.
They could become
really rich as a superhero,
but really they just wanted them
as cannon fodder for their testing.
if they wound up developing really cool
or really marketable
useful superpowers,
that was just a bonus side effect.
the reason why Homelander was an
exception is because he was actually
artificially created in a lab
they took genetic material
from Soldier Boy and tried to refine
his DNA to make an even more powerful
superhero in that became homelander.
there is that across history.
You have all these different people
secretly submitting their children
for testing to get compounded
when they're babies.
well why ends up happening
is that a lot of them don't develop
any kind of useful superpowers
or they have really weak superpowers
that BART doesn't really care about,
or they just wind up being failures
they're either cast aside
or the parents can't deal with them
because their powers are
too out of control or they're too powerful
they would get sent to places
like Red River Institute,
which are basically
like all the compound babies
that nobody could control
that's actually where one of the main
characters comes from here.
Marie Morrow it looks like her
power is blood manipulation, veins,
arteries manipulation
and a regenerative healing factor
talking about Marvel, DC references,
like all the characters are meant to be
comic book
references or parodies in some way,
she'd be a little bit more like Carnage
from the Marvel Universe based on the way
he uses his powers differently from Venom
and the other Symbiotes.
you could also make an avatar, The Last
Airbender blood bending reference to
And they're actually doing a Netflix
live action avatar,
The Last Airbender,
which I'll be doing videos for.
I've already done
a trailer video for that,
so I'll post a link down
the description below.
she even seems like she was that
accidentally using her powers to blow up
this dude's junk, which he jokes
about with one of the other characters
during the trailer.
You see her go back to Red River Institute
and use her powers again.
they make it seem like
she has a solid chance
of being the winning student
and making it onto the seven.
but the big twist.
Or she might wind up figuring out
what's really going on here,
like the truth of all of this
sort of the same way that Victoria Newman
learned the secret of what was going on
when she was at Red River
Institute was adopted by Stan Edgar
in part of this whole box system
to get into the White House.
summary might wind up going a little bit
sinister towards
the end of the series as well too.
I don't know how many seasons
this is going to wind up running though,
so obviously they're not going
to completely finished during season one
because this is their freshman class
during this first season Clancy Brown.
Seems like he's playing
a pretty big character on the show.
His name is Richard Brinkerhoff.
They call him Brink.
They don't say exactly how he fits
into the universe of the boys.
He's not from the comics,
but because he wrote these books,
he sounds like he's
one of the researchers on board Steam
trying to cool through all these compound
babies to find one that's good enough
to join the seven in market
and make a bunch of money off of Patrick
Schwarzenegger
is playing a character called Golden Boy,
the only time he uses his powers
in the trailer.
We see his eyes light up like butchers
when he was on the temporary compound,
be about to use his eye lasers.
But they actually say that his power
is controlling fire,
making him a little bit
more like pyro in the Marvel Universe.
within the boys universe,
that would make him a little bit
more like the Lamplighter character
who is also a bit of a pyro reference,
which is funny because he was played
by the character
who played Iceman during the X-Men movies.
I don't know if his character on The Boys
is going to be related to Lamplighter
Character or they use some genetic
material from Lamplighter to create him.
He might just have similar powers.
I think the idea here,
though, in the trailer
is he's meant to be a misdirect,
like they call it in Golden Boy,
but it's meant to be ironic.
Ultimately,
like he thinks he's nearly as powerful
as homelander in has a shot of winning
this and joining the seven.
But really of a bunch of other students
who have crazy powers
that know how to use them way
more usefully.
this character is Emma Shaw.
She has Ant-Man shrinking powers
just like Termite,
who also exploded
adduce junk back in Season three.
lot of dos jokes getting exploded during
the boy is just in general.
So everybody watch out Chance
Perdomo here is playing Andre Anderson.
His powers are metal manipulation,
just like Magneto.
His father is also a compound
B super called polarity,
which is a Polaris reference from X-Men
in the Marvel Universe.
when they say he's his son, I'm
assuming he didn't get his powers
biologically when he was born
because Ryan on the Boys is supposed to be
the first example of that as Homelander's
natural born son.
Previously, they believe the compound
would make superheroes sterile.
what might have happened is the polarity
probably had his son Andre, dosed
with compound B as part of the trials
when he was born or after he was born.
And he just happened
to get the same type of powers.
Unless they radically changed the comics
This is Kate Dunlap.
She has telepathic powers.
I think that's meant to be a Jean
Gray X-Men reference.
It also seems like she's Golden Boy's
girlfriend during the series.
this is Jordan.
It looks like his powers are shapeshifting
and some kind of forcefield projection
because he keeps changing
between male and female forms.
The man is the actor's natural form,
even though the first time we see them,
they're in female form.
that would make them like a morph
or a mystique.
X-Men reference in the Forge
fields are similar
to Invisible Woman of the Fantastic Four.
speaking of Morph,
he's also supposed to be back on the main
X-Men team during X-Men 97 Season one.
I'll be doing full videos for that.
We should get a trailer
sometime in the next couple of months.
they were selling a whole bunch of X-Men
merch for the show at Comic-Con.
this is Sam Reardon
wearing the Homelander t shirt
when they're all partying in the hallway.
Later in the trailer, he punches his fist
through one of the security guards.
So I'm assuming he just
has a version of super strength.
There's a bunch of characters
whose powers they have unspecified,
but they also list a bunch of the other
students names on this list, ranking them
at any given time during the semester.
like I said,
this is more of a Hunger Games thing.
Like you rank people in a normal school,
but the idea here is
they're all slowly killing each other off
for that number one spot.
They do an extended puppet scene here.
The puppet is named Gary.
I'm assuming this has something to do
with the way one of their powers work
in the hallway seem
similar to the aftermath scene here
with the kid around all the dead bodies.
So the puppet might be him
just hallucinating like black noir
was when he was using his powers
to kill all these people.
when the scientists are messing
with one of them in the background,
there's a payback poster with Soulja
Boy on it. The rest of the team.
The idea is at the end of season three,
Soulja Boy couldn't naturally be killed.
He was so powerful,
so they had to put him into deep storage,
basically put him on ice again,
Jensen Ackles did say
there was always a chance
he could come back in the future season,
but I'm pretty sure
that he's not going to come back
during season four.
Victoria Newman comes back for the series.
Remember,
she's already won the presidential bids.
What seems like she's actually going
to become the vice president
most of the other big Vought related
characters are back to like Ashley is back
because she's probably
keeping tabs on the program
because technically she's
the new Vought CEO and will be responsible
for the school trying to find fresh meat
for the Grinder, so to speak.
More superheroes
that could make more money off of really,
though, when it comes to running Vought
like controlling the company.
Homelander is in control and he just tells
Ashley what he wants to do.
Ashley takes care of the day to day
to keep the company actually running
during the trailer,
everything starts going crazy.
People start killing each other.
It looks at the soldiers, the security
guards here have some kind of A.C.
Power weapon
meant for controlling the students
or trying to control them
when they get out of control.
not sure what p.J Burns director
character is doing during the series.
He probably is trying to film
more commercials using the kids
because they also have that
funny turbo rush
and joke that they're doing with Andre
where he says the drink totally sucks.
Like the drink is terrible.
I would never drink this, that's
meant to be A-Train signature product
that he's trying to sling
he filmed an entire music video for it
during season three
that was meant to be a parody
of the real life
terrible Pepsi commercial Kendall Jenner
did a couple of years ago during the riots
during the background scene here
you actually see what looks like
a groundhog poster
for race to Death movie that he filmed.
He's meant to be like the Boys
Universe version of Wolverine,
except he has hammers four hands
instead of claws in his hands,
who was also featured
during the animated Boys series.
I don't know if they're ever going to do
a season two of that animated boy series.
Some of the episodes
are actually pretty solid.
but I think part of the idea is that
when they start releasing more trailers,
they'll reveal more about what's
actually going on with the characters,
what their superhero names are,
what their powers are.
pretty sure a solid chunk of these
will wind up getting killed off
through the course of season one, though
there's still a whole bunch
that we don't know about
what's going on in this.
There's still a lot of mysteries.
So if you have any big questions
that I didn't answer during the trailer
or any Big East race that you spotted
that I didn't talk about,
just write them below in the comments
there was a whole bunch of stuff
that released this weekend
as part of Comic-Con.
I'll put links for all that stuff down
in the description below in my full Marvel
Secret Invasion
episode 6 video we'll post on Wednesday
after they release it,
so be sure to enable it
first for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for my secret invasion
finale video
and click here for my new
Invincible season 2 Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!